well we need to do a much better
education program and a lot of people
you know when we have like these
tsunamis that you've seen you know
there's a tsunami every two weeks in
this world we have 40 tsunamis going on
right now they have them every two weeks
you don't read about them they're
they're called silent tsunamis but you
know we have 25,000 people that die
every day so there's a tsunami going on
all the time and when we do publicize it
I mean people in America respond very
well but there's also a lot of
nonprofits that crop up on a TV station
that you got to be careful of because
they're asking for money and they want
to load up 747s and take food over there
right away and they dumped it on the
ground and I've seen this where the food
has just dumped on the ground you know
sometimes I've heard about where they
put Gatorade in there and cornflakes and
stuff like that will people and I offer
to they don't need that stuff and that
stuff just go to waste it's a waste of
taxpayers money even though it's private
and there's a lot of things that are
wasted so I you know when you're going
to donate if you're going to donate
money instead of a voluntary time be
very careful who you donate to and take
a good look at them and see what kind of
administrative costs that they have and
what it costs for them to put programs
into the field and and see what kind of
programs I mean and see if they work and
see what kind of criticism they have
because people write critiques of them
and they're evaluated would be real
careful about people that advertise a
lot on TV and but there are some good
ones World Vision Catholic Relief
Services you know cares the Oxfam these
are these are good groups Save the
Children
these are very good groups and there are
indigenous groups in countries that are
very very good there is a there is a
project in Ethiopia it's by far it's
it's run by an Ethiopian couple that I
know very well it's the finest project
I've ever seen it's the most complete
holistic project it's got a hospital
it's got an elementary school it's got a
high school it's got a vocational ad
they they work with the community it's a
it's an organization that was planted
right in the middle of a Muslim
community and they work with the Muslims
Christians everybody and it's just most
amazing wonderful project it's called
Project mercy and you would measure if
you're ever going to do a project ever
contribute to a project I would
contribute to this one but if you're
ever going to measure a project I would
measure all projects in the world not
just Africa by this one it's about two
hours south of addis beautiful project
absolutely perfect matter of fact if you
ever going to do a project and I don't
know if you do projects you know where
you do summer projects overseas this is
the project where I would send I've set
my daughter there i mean i i've sent a
lot of young people there I mean this is
where I would go and get training this
is it's that good mm-hmm project mercy
it's home office is out of Fort Wayne
Indiana it's run by to Ethiopian it's an
indigenous NGO it's the finest project
in all of I say in the world I've seen
300 projects it's the best